Nonnie you visa-free travelers will have  to get authorization before they arrive  in the EU members are voting on this new  system to improve EU border controls  members continue the exchange of views  with EU leaders on the future of Europe  polish Prime Minister Matteo Swarovski  is coming to debate the issue the boom  in the 3d printing market also opens the  door to intellectual property and civil  liability issues Parliament wants  innovation and consumer protection to go  hand in hand  the needs of online users must be  balanced against artists rights members  want to ensure that online access  doesn't jeopardize EU copyright looms  lorry drivers should be treated equally  across the EU Parliament wants to  prevent social dumping and improve  drivers working conditions